all right you know it's the summer movie
season when the Avengers is out in
theaters we get a new trailer for The
Dark Knight Rises and then we get a new
trailer for the amazing spider-man yeah
we're gonna talk about that trailer now
this life is not an easy one now this
tree that looks good and I'm glad this
trailer came out because among the
Avengers being in theaters and a new
Dark Knight Rises trailer and people
getting excited about both of those
movies it's easy to forget that between
these two monsters is a little-known
movie coming out for a small character
called spider-man yeah that's a big deal
and the main thing about this trailer is
it goes deeper into the fact that Peter
Parker finding out about his parents is
a big deal in this movie but the one
thing that is haunting me my entire life
is finding the truth about my parents I
know his parents were like shield agents
they're probably not gonna be shield
agents in this movie probably gonna be
like CIA or something this movie's like
nope we're going that route it's a big
deal for this story and that's cool as
long as they make it fit it does look
like it ties in with the overall story
of this movie and that's cool who is
that guy who's Darth Sidious over here
talking to dr. Connors but is that the
proto goblin that we heard was gonna be
in the movie that we heard he wasn't
than he was wasn't was now maybe is I
don't know but I think Darth evil over
here needs to step up who is he and in
this trailer we get a couple glimpses of
the lizard he pretty much looks exactly
like the concept art for the lizard if
you were disappointed the concept art
you probably gonna be disappointed about
this if you like the concept art
probably gonna like how he looks in the
movie now personally my favorite part of
this trailer I'm gonna talk about it
it's the funniest part of the trailer
usually I leave these things for you to
see but I'm gonna talk about this
because it's hilarious I laughed like
twice
[Music]
don't dress like a Cartier we found my
weakness it's small knives how is that
not hilarious apparently this is before
Crocodile Dundee came to New York
because he'd be singing a different song
let me tell you now that's a knife I'm
just saying I'd like to see that other
than that this trailer is pretty much
stuff we already knew I mean the cops
are chasing spider-man and Gwen Stacy's
awesome because she's Emma Stone and
she's ridiculously hot and has a cute
smile Andrew Garfield though looks like
a perfect Peter Parker I was a little
skeptical about his age but now I'm
crossing over to okay fine The Dude's 28
when they filmed this movie but I don't
care he's Peter Parker hope he doesn't
suck however the only bummer about this
trailer was the bummer about the last
trailer I think with all the trailers
combined if you just look at everything
that happens you could probably piece
together the entire movie the big beam
and the trailer shoots up in the sky
it's like oh I gotta take out the
antenna look at that I did and people
know I did because they saw in the
trailer I don't like it when trailers do
that you know what I really like about
the comic book movies of this summer is
that they're all different the Avengers
is not like The Dark Knight Rises the
Dark Knight Rises is not gonna be like
spider-man spider-man is not gonna be
like The Avengers so you shouldn't
really be like oh there's this one
better than this one what's the best one
they're all different movies so just
enjoy them all or hate them oh I don't
know in the end the amazing spider-man
looks really cool I'm really glad this
trailer came out because to be honest I
all before God for the amazing
spider-man was coming out this summer
other movies started to eclipse it so
now it's back on my mind so the amazing
spider-man have you seen the new trailer
what do you think about it comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]